Uh, Oum, Sumaya? Sumaya? Yes, yes. Sorry
about that. I was actually put myself on
mute. Um, so the question is did Jesus
mention Muhammad sallallahu alayhi
wasallam? Yeah, he did. Okay, where did
he mention
>> he did. Um, so when he said that, um, so
that he has to leave and so in order for
it to the comforter to come he has to
leave, correct? But you guys believe the
comforter is, um, the Holy Spirit,
correct? Just want to make sure I'm
understanding that correctly. See, yeah,
that's what Jesus
That's Ooh,
kid, that [laughter] kid back
>> I'm I'm I'm good. Sorry about that. Can
y'all stop?
Don't worry about the background. I just
wanted to say something real quick. I'm
not going to stay on too long. But the
reason The thing is the
So I just want to understand because it
doesn't make sense when you guys say the
Holy Spirit because the Holy Spirit If
you put it that way, the Holy Spirit was
always here. Mhm.
>> So, how why would he say in order for
this for the comforter to come I have to
go? Yeah.
>> And also, what evidence Hold on one
thing. What evidence do you have that
the Holy Spirit even came with any type
of comforting Mhm. after Jesus left?
That's a good question. So, before So,
um, ma'am, you your kids are killing it
in the background, sis. No, those are
not my kids. I'm I came to visit, so
they're not my kids.
>> Oh, man. Can Can you tell them to go to
the next room or something? My God.
>> Yeah, I'm I'm going to mute myself. I'm
going to mute myself. I I feel like they
knew that you was coming on live and got
loud on purpose. Like that's like kids
just be doing stuff like that. All
right. So, um, let me do with your first
question. So, your first question is how
does it make sense that this is talking
about the Holy there,
then why would Jesus have to say that
he's going back or he's going away for
the Holy Spirit to come if the Holy
Spirit has always been there in the in
the first place, right? So, good
question. So, um,
John 14 answers this. So, and this is
where he first begins to talk about the
comforter.
Okay? Let me do John. So, in John 14:26,
this is where we see Jesus explicitly
say that the helper the comforter is the
Holy Spirit, okay?
So, he says, "But the helper, the Holy
Spirit, whom the Father will send in my
name, he will teach you all things and
bring to your remembrance all that I
have said to you." Okay? So, Jesus
explicitly tells us that the helper is
the Holy Spirit. So, that's that's step
number one in the foundation that we
have to set. So, are you with me so far?
Cuz then I'm going to answer I'm I'm
about to answer the question that you
asked. But are you with me so far?
>> I hear what you're saying. I hear what
you're saying. You can keep going. All
right. So, now, why it was So, what is
Jesus talking about then when he says
that I have to go away if I don't go
away the helper won't come to you? Well,
it's in the way that the helper that the
Holy Spirit comes to the believers.
Okay? So, watch this. So, he says in
verse 16,
"And I will ask the Father, and he will
give you another helper to be with you
forever,
even the Spirit of truth, whom the world
cannot receive, because it neither sees
him nor knows him.
But you know him, for he dwells with you
and will be in you." Okay? So, important
things here. Jesus says that the
disciples, cuz he's talking to his
disciples, he says, "You know him. You
know this helper that I'm talking about
already. For he dwells with you. He's
already here. He lives with you now,
right? And how is that? Because the Holy
Spirit is on Jesus. Wherever Jesus is,
the Holy Spirit is because the Holy
Spirit came down on Jesus at his
baptism. So, wherever Jesus goes, the
Holy Spirit has indwelt in Jesus. So,
with when the disciples are in the
presence of Jesus, they are also in the
presence of the Holy Spirit. So, that's
how they know who the Holy Spirit is
already because the Holy Spirit's there
indwelt in Jesus, and he's already with
them.
However, the Holy Spirit is not in them
yet. He does He dwells with them, but he
doesn't dwell in them. And so, this is
what Jesus says. He says, "You know him,
for he dwells with you and will be in
you." So, that's a future tense. He's
already with you, but in the future he's
going to be in you.
Right? So, that's when Jesus says, "When
I go, the Holy Spirit will come, the
helper will come." And the way that he's
coming, not just that he's going to be
with them, but he's going to dwell in
them. He's going to be in them. That is
the way in which he is coming to them.
Does that make sense?
>> No, but
what about John Is it John 16:7 or 16:17
when he says that Wait. Wait. Wait.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
>> so but the Holy
The Holy Spirit was present when Wait.
>> Okay, the Holy Spirit was present when
he was there. So, so then that means if
you put it that way, then that's a
contradiction, right? You're basically
say stating he didn't know because the
statement he made didn't end up being
the truth, What did What did you
understand from what I said? No, but
what you said is not similar to It
didn't answer my question because
technically speaking, if it was present
at the time, how can it Okay, he said,
"I have to go in order for it to come."
Correct? The comforter. Wait. Wait.
Wait, Oum. We got to slow down, okay?
What did you understand from what I
said? I didn't
It's not like I can't understand. It
just does not make sense.
>> I agree. I don't I don't think you can't
understand. You're saying that it did it
what I said didn't make sense. So, what
what did I say?
>> answering
Okay, it's not answering my question cuz
I'm asking You're making me feel like
you wasn't listening.
>> in order for him to leave that the
comforter has to come Okay, he has to
leave for the comforter to come. If the
comforter was present during the time
Not not not the comforter, but if the
Holy Spirit was present during the time
that he was there, how can that how
would that make sense for that to be the
comforter? Okay. So, I'll I'll say it
again. Matter Matter of fact, I won't
say it this time. This time I'm going to
have you I'm going to have you follow
along with me because I feel like I feel
like you wasn't listening at all, to be
honest with you. Because if you were
listening, you would you would you
wouldn't say what you're saying right
now. Okay. So,
>> It's okay.
I I know you can't answer it. It's okay.
>> you think that. I I already did. You're
just not listening.
>> I I honestly know you can't cuz you're
going to listen no matter what. You're
going to listen.
>> if Let's see if I'm going to say
something right.
>> It's really simple.
>> Now you're manifesting. Why are you
talking over me now?
>> No, no, I'm not. To be honest with you,
I I came in here with good good faith. I
promise you because I just wanted to
clarify this part here. I I I I I trust
you. Hold on. I trust you.
>> Okay. So, walk So, walk with me, okay?
Walk with me. He says, "And I will ask
the Father and he will give you another
comforter to be with you forever." You
with me so far? Talking to his
disciples, right? You with me? I'm here.
I'm here. Keep going. Okay. "Even the
Spirit of truth." So, that comforter
that's going to come to the disciples
and be with them forever is the Spirit
of truth, whom the world cannot receive
because it neither sees him
nor knows him. But you know him." Jesus
just said that the that the disciples
know the comforter already, correct?
Can't hear you if you're talking. No,
I'm listening. I'm listening. So, do do
you affirm what I just read that Jesus
just said that his disciples know the
comforter?
Right?
>> Okay, go ahead. Okay. So, they know the
comforter. They didn't know Muhammad, so
that's impossible. Can't be Muhammad.
They know the comforter. Now, here's why
they know the comforter. He says, "You
know him
because
he dwells with you." He's already here.
You hear that? So, Jesus says the
comforter is already there with them,
right?
>> Okay, so I have a question. Is that in
the New Testament or the Old Testament?
>> the New Testament. Just walk with me.
>> Exactly. Exactly.
>> What What What comforter passage
Yeah, but it Okay. Okay.
>> Just walk with me. That original passage
was in the Old Testament, correct?
>> No. No.
>> The what you're stating is in the old is
in the New Testament. Everything
[laughter]
>> You just said it's not in the Old
Testament. Oum, everything in about the
comforter
when Jesus is mentioning the comforter,
everything is in the in the New
Testament, okay? I'm asking if it's in
I'm talking about what you just said.
I'm not talking about the comforter
part. I'm talking about the whole about
them the comforter being with in my
among them. It's in the It's in the New
Testament. I'm
>> Is it in the Old Testament is what I
asked. No. Okay. That's my point. Now,
I'm going to drop off. Wait, don't drop
off yet.
>> That's my point.
>> Now, watch this. Now, watch this. It's
not in the Old Testament. Well, hold on
a second. So, watch what he says here.
He says
>> it.
>> Notice what you So, No, no, no, no, no.
You said that you came in good faith and
you're not listening. You're doing it on
purpose. And then you're about to go
off.
>> listening. And I just told you it don't
make sense. So, pay attention. So,
according to Jesus, the comforter is
already there, correct?
>> According to what? The New Testament,
correct?
>> According to Jesus, what I just read,
the comforter is there with the
disciples, correct?
>> That's why I asked you. Then in terms of
him saying the comforter is being among
them at that moment, is that in the Old
Testament or the New Testament?
>> okay? No, I am okay cuz we're talking
about two different things. I'm I'm I'm
I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm
I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm
>> No, but about it being among them, is it
in the New Testament? I asked you. It's
not. No, it is not. When Jesus talks
about the comforter, those are all New
Testament passages, girl. All of it.
>> Okay, that's why I'm asking you. Okay,
got you. Keep going. Jeez. So, Jesus
says that he's already there with them.
Agreed? Okay. Okay. Now, listen to this
next part. It's very important cuz this
answers your question. "For he dwells
with you." I need you to come back to
the app cuz I'm not sure if you're
listening. I need to make sure you're
listening. No, I'm I can hear you
whether I'm in the app or not.
>> No, but you hearing me and listening are
two different things. I need you to
listen, sis, cuz I said this before and
you didn't hear what I said. So, I need
you to listen. I need you to walk with
me. So, he says,
"Because he You know him
because he dwells with you." He's
already there. "And will" So, will is
future. In the future will be in you."
So, right now he's with them,
but he's not in them yet. In the future,
he's going to be in them. You understand
that? What he just said? No, I
I I hear what you're saying. So, do you
hear how Jesus said in the future the
comforter will be inside of them? No,
Jesus didn't say that. But if you
believe that, then that's okay.
>> Well, I'm I'm I'm reading it off I'm
reading the red letters. John 14:17.
The comforter passages.
>> No, you you could believe what he said
based on your scripture, but I don't
believe that.
>> All right. I know No worries. I'm
I'm I'm
I'm just asking, can you be honest with
the text?
Wait, before you ask anything,
can you So you can So you're Can you be
honest with the text that according to
the text, Jesus says the comforter will
be inside the of the the disciples. Can
we agree?
That's what he says in the text.
Okay. All right. Now Now follow me. Keep
following me, okay? We're walking
through this. So, since Jesus is there,
the comforter does not indwell them.
He's not living in them. He's there, but
he's not in them yet.
When he goes away, that's when he will
come and be inside of them.
Make sense?
Okay, no worries.
But what I said was is that he's there
with them. When Jesus goes away, though,
when he goes away, the comforter will
then be inside them. He will come and be
inside them, not just with them. He'll
be inside them now. You understand the
difference? That's That's the part that
I I mean I've never seen I never heard
of a verse that says he that the
comforter is going to be inside them. I
just gave it to you. John 6 John 14:17.
I'll say it again. Are you You said that
you were listening. You said you were
listening,
Somaya. You there? Hello. Did you Did
you see the verse? Yeah, I'm reading.
You don't You don't have to go off
screen. You want me to just show it on
the screen so that you can see it. Do
you want Do you want me to just show Go
to John Go to Go to John 14:20.
No, not yet. We're in verse verse 6
verse 17 so that you can see the verse
that I just told you about. Did you see
the verse? Put it on your screen so that
I don't have to get out the What is it
called? Okay. It's right here. Verse 17.
"Even the Spirit of truth, whom the
world cannot receive, because it neither
sees him nor knows him, but you know
him, for he dwells with you and will be
in you." You see that part? Yeah, I'm
reading. So you see how Jesus says the
comforter
in the future is going to be inside of
them. Wait, but will be in you does not
necessarily mean inside of you. It could
be with like among you basically.
>> No, cuz he already says he's among you.
He says he dwells with you and will be
in you. The word in you literally means
to be inside.
To indwell. Come on, sis. Let's be
honest with the text. No, no. I'm Okay.
Okay.
Why would you Why would you think that
the text is just referring to that
specific moment and not it could have
been a future moment where it's telling
the people during that time, even if
it's Prophet Muhammad at the time, so so
that they he will It could Okay.
Basically, You think Muhammad is going
to be Can Muhammad dwell you? Can
Muhammad be in you? That's what I'm
saying. I don't believe it's with like
with in you, but among you basically.
>> say that. But it doesn't say that. It
says in you, right? Okay, but what is
the original What does the original text
say?
That's a translation. You're trying
hard, [laughter] aren't you?
>> [laughter]
[gasps]
>> You know what got me more is you is you
laughing, too. You laughing as well got
me. Cuz you Cuz you know what you know,
man. Come on, dog. Come on, Somaya. This
can't possibly be Muhammad, correct? Cuz
Muhammad can't be in you. He's a human
being. Right? Somaya, you got to come
off You got to come off mute. No, I was
reading I was reading I was reading.
What What are you reading? Okay, hold
on. Can you let somebody up real quick
that can explain it?
>> No. No, there's nobody else to
There's no cuz I'm explaining it to you.
I'm helping you out right now.
>> There is No, no, no. No, I'm not talking
about your side of it. I have someone
that can explain it. There is no There
is no my side of it. It's just the
scripture. I don't need my side. I'm
just giving you the verse.
>> or not? Are you Are you Are you going to
let them up or not? No, the answer is
I'm not I'm not Listen, I'm not
knowledgeable on the Bible. I'm just
going by what So then why are you Why
are you fighting me on it if you're not
knowledgeable on the Bible?
>> I'm not fighting you. I'm asking. No,
no. I came to you with a question.
[laughter] For some reason that didn't
make sense to me, okay? Okay, so So
that's That's the only reason why I came
up. So Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
Wait. Slow down. Slow down. So
So in light of what you asked, does it
make sense now that in the future
the Holy Spirit, at first, he was there
with them cuz he says it dwells with
them. He was there with them, but he was
not in them yet. When Jesus goes away,
he's going to send the comforter back to
us and he's going to be in the believers
this time, not just with them and among
them, but in them this time. Does he Do
you Does that make sense? Are you going
to let the person that I told you I have
someone that can come up and answer it?
If you want to come and say that I'm
getting cooked, how am I getting cooked?
She ain't getting cooked.
We We just talked
Ignore the comments, please. Ignore
Somaya, please ignore the comments.
Ignore the I'm Do you hear me saying
that? No, I'm not worried about the
comments. I promise you that it it
Listen. Listen, I'm not worried about
that. Okay, good.
>> Can you let Can you Are you going to let
him up or not? No, I'm not letting
nobody up. It's me and you.
>> Okay, so then I'm going to drop. All
right, bye. Cuz he can answer.
>> BYE, FELICIA. ALL RIGHT, HOLD ON.
>> [laughter]
>> You're doing too much. I swear. Bye,
Felicia. Shoo. Bye. What What WHAT WE
WHAT WE DOING HERE, MAN? BYE, FELICIA.
Good googly moogly. Came up here in good
faith, fought me on the scripture tooth
and nail, and and didn't even want to
concede to what the text said. Come on,
man. What we doing here?
What we doing here? What in the world
are we doing here? Oh my mom, man. My
mom is crazy, man. My mom said kick her.
>> [gasps]
>> Uh shoot. Uh but her second question was
And what is the proof that the Holy
Spirit came and brought comfort? What is
the proof that the Holy Spirit actually
came and brought that comfort? It's a
great question, sis. Great great
question. Great question.
Let's go. Great question. I love that
question. Watch this. I love I love
talking about the Holy Spirit. He is so
amazing. There is none like him. Gentle
and kind, intercedes on our behalf,
guides us and teaches us, gives us all
the tools
to combat the devil and falsehoods and
satanic religions like Islam. The Holy
Spirit gives us that ability to read and
understand the Quran when Muslims can't
and to teach them. Let's go into This is
Acts chapter 2, ladies and gentlemen.
When the day of Pentecost arrived, they
were all together in one place.
And suddenly there from heaven there
came
a sound like a mighty rushing wind, and
it filled the entire house where they
were sitting. And divided tongues as a
fire appeared to them and rested on each
one of them. And they were all filled
with the Holy Spirit and began to speak
in other tongues as the Spirit gave them
utterance. So here we have the arrival
of the Holy Spirit indwelling the
believers on the day of Pentecost,
showing up in a mighty way like he
usually does.
Like he did on the mountain before with
Elijah.
Like he did
throughout the wilderness in the desert
through
in and in Exodus with the Israelites.
Now watch. Watch what the Holy Spirit
does for us besides give miraculous
power and fruit. Watch what the Holy
Spirit does. Therefore, there is
therefore now no condemnation for those
who are in Christ Jesus. For the law of
the Spirit of life has set you free
in Christ Jesus from the law of sin and
death.
Wow.
Thank [clears throat] you, Holy Spirit.
The Spirit of life with his law has set
us free in Christ Jesus. When you say
freedom is comfort, isn't freedom
comfort? He brought us freedom in Christ
Jesus from the law of sin and death.
It's by the Spirit of life. The Holy
Spirit. Let's keep going. For God has
done what the law weakened by the flesh
could not do by sending his own son in
the likeness of sinful flesh and for
sin, he condemned sin in the flesh in
order that the righteous requirement of
the law might be fulfilled in us
who walk not according to the flesh but
according to the Spirit. Woo. Look how
the Holy Spirit got us moving, man.
Walking in Christ.
Walking in the newness of life. For
those who live according to the flesh
set their minds on the things of the
flesh.
But those who live according to the
Spirit set their minds on the things of
the Spirit.
For to set the mind on the flesh is
death, but to set the mind on the Spirit
is life and peace.
Woo. Give me proof where the Holy Spirit
came and gave us comfort. What? I'm glad
you asked that. This is Romans chapter
8. I just read to you verses 1 to 6 so
far. To set the mind Verse 6. To set the
mind on the flesh is death.
But to set the mind on the Spirit on the
Holy Spirit
is life and peace. You mean the Holy
Spirit offers us peace
and life? Grants us life? Peace?
Freedom? You want proof that the Holy
Spirit came and gives us comfort?
It's right here.
What do you mean, proof? Now show me
where Muhammad did this.
Muhammad brought death. Muhammad brought
death
and catastrophe. Confusion. He brought
wife beating. He brought child
molestation. He brought the unaliving
of non-believers.
The Spirit brings life and peace. For
the mind that is set on the flesh is
hostile to God. Sounds familiar, doesn't
it? For it does not submit to God's law.
Indeed, it cannot. Those who are in the
flesh cannot please God. So if we are in
the Holy Spirit, that's how we can
please God. And it's only by the Holy
Spirit, walking in the Spirit, having
our minds set on the Spirit, that we
have that peace of mind. That life. Not
walking [snorts] around dead.
Walking around as dead meat dead flesh,
but we're walking around in the fullness
of life with peace on our minds and
sound understanding and strength, and as
a result of that we please God. Watch
this. You, however, are not in the flesh
but in the Spirit. Not among the Spirit.
You're in the Spirit. If in fact the
Spirit of God dwells in you. Say that
again.
Say that again Paul. You are not in the
flesh but you're in the spirit if in
fact the spirit of God dwells in you.
Watch what he says here. This is
beautiful. Anyone who does not have the
spirit of Christ does not belong to him.
Wait, didn't he just say the spirit of
God? Didn't he just say the spirit of
God? Let me hold on Paul, let me read
that again. If in fact the spirit of God
dwells in you. Anyone who does not have
the spirit of Christ does not belong to
him. Wait, so the spirit of God is the
SPIRIT OF CHRIST? WHAT? COME ON. STOP
IT.
There's your trinity. The the Holy
Spirit belongs to both God the Father
and to Christ. The Holy Spirit is the
Holy Spirit of God the Father and the
spirit of Christ.
He belongs to them both. That's good
Bible. That's good Bible. Deity of
Christ where? There's your trinity. Now
watch what he says. What? Look, watch
what he says.
Anyone who does not have the spirit of
Christ does not belong to him. Wait, you
mean to tell me that we belong to
Christ? Oh, we preaching over here baby.
We belong to Christ? But I thought we
only belong to God. Let's keep going.
Watch what he says. But if Christ is in
you. Stop it. I thought he's just a mere
prophet. A mere messenger. May his peace
be upon us. If Christ is in you,
although the body is dead because of
sin, the spirit is life because of
righteousness. If the spirit of him who
raised Jesus from the dead dwells in
you, he who raised Christ from the dead
will also give life to your mortal
bodies through his spirit who dwells in
you. Stop playing with me. Don't play on
the Holy Spirit. Don't play on the Holy
Spirit. Don't play don't play with the
Holy Spirit. The Holy Spirit gets slept
on by these Moomenoons and these
Unitarians. Don't sleep on the Holy
Spirit. Don't you do it. It is by the
spirit that you have life.
It is by the spirit that you are able to
please God. It is by the spirit that
you're able to confess the Lord as your
savior. It's by the spirit that you have
peace. It's by the spirit that you have
a sound mind.
Y'all think I'm playing? Hold on. Hold
on. Hold on. Y'all Y'all Y'all Y'all
Y'all Y'all think I'm just talking.
Y'all think I'm just talking around
here. Hold on. Let's What's the only
thing we do around here chat? What's the
only thing we do around here? Y'all let
me know. What's the only thing we do? We
just read, right? Watch what it says
about the Holy Spirit here. Second
Timothy chapter 1 verse 7. Watch this. I
love this verse. Watch this. For God
gave us
a spirit not of fear, not of fear, not
fear, not fear, not terror, not fear.
For God gave us a spirit not of fear but
of power and love and self-control. A
sound mind. Where's the proof that the
Holy Spirit came and gave us comfort?
I'm glad you asked sister. I'm glad you
asked cuz I was able to just spend the
last 10 to 15 minutes
glorifying the Holy Spirit and
highlighting the
very spirit of our God. The promised
gift of the Holy Spirit and the son of
God. The gift of the son of God. The
gift of the Father that he bestowed on
us to walk with us, to live in us, to
dwell us. He gave us not the spirit of
fear which you Muslims experience. You
can't ask questions. You can't miss a
fast. You can't miss prayer. You got to
do this and do that. You're in fear. Not
in reverence but in actual fear. You're
afraid. You don't even know where you're
going to go when you die. But our God
gave us the spirit of power.
We are not weak. We are not timid. We
are bold. We are courageous.
Unapologetically
uh children of the of God.
Unapologetically children of the way.
Unapologetically Christian. Followers of
our Lord Jesus Christ. Boldly
proclaiming Christ on the internet in
front of thousands. Despite the slander.
Despite the the
the lies. Despite the ridicule. Despite
the name-calling. Despite the trolls.
Spirit of the of power and of love. We
love you despite the slander.
We love you despite your falsehood. We
love you despite your hardheadedness and
your pride. We love you despite your
arrogance. We come here three times a
day, three times a week, throughout the
week without on YouTube giving the
gospel because we love you. Because
that's the spirit of God in us working.
Power and love and a sound mind,
self-control. You can't move us. You
can't move me. Nothing you say can move
me.
Your slander won't move me. Won't worry
me. Won't trouble me.
Your hate, your lies won't won't trouble
me. Won't get me out of my character.
I have the spirit of God dwelling in me.
The spirit of God I feel like Darron
Dorsey right now. If I was Darron If I
was Darron Dorsey, I'll be like, I got
the spirit of God dwelling in me. The
spirit of God is in me.
And he's in you. Where Darron Dorsey at
man? We need your mannerisms Darron.
The spirit of power and of love and a
sound mind dwelling with inside of me
and inside of you. I love Darron man.
That's the Holy Spirit. Proof that he
has come
and he has given us comfort. With that
being said man, that's our session
today. That's the gospel.
That's [clears throat] Bible.
And
man
we went through this entire stream guys
and not a single Muslim was able to
demonstrate to us that Jesus mentions
Muhammad. Not a single one was able to
to show us a reference where Jesus
mentioned Muhammad. So the Quran's claim
in chapter 61 verse 6 that Jesus
mentioned a messenger named Ahmad to
come after him is a lie. The Quran lied.
The Quran made a false claim, a false
statement. Put words in the in the mouth
of our Lord Jesus. Lied. And proved
itself to be false yet again.